I just realized I love Game of Thrones
and I hate spoilers yet Here I am
reading a script for Game of Thrones
Season six spoilers I need to reevaluate
my life choices ready for some Game of
Thrones Season six boilers you know
nothing Jon Snow
no well too bad the season finale
confirmed the long-held fan theory that
Jon Snow is Ty Gary and blood now the
big questions looming over the newly
crowned king in the north
are if when and how he and his
biological aren't the nearest eye garyun
will learn about their connection and if
that makes some friends or foes but
could Danny's trusty sidekick be the one
to ultimately bring the family together
here's our draw a moment will unite
Daenerys and Jon Snow in Game of Thrones
shades of grey scale the last glimpse we
got of Jorah was when Daenerys sent him
away on horseback to find a cure for his
case of greyscale thanks to princess
Shireen Baratheon we know that a cure
must exist for the disease since she had
it as a baby and was healed details on
who or what saved her back then unclear
but Jorah is resourceful enough to find
out well let's hope so
maybe he'll return to Qarth in
consultive quake the mysterious masked
shadow binder who's both a prophet and
good of protective body paint she's one
of the characters missing from season
six and she's due for a comeback
or perhaps Aurora will run into mother
Sandra the red witch and strike a deal
after all she's a free agent now and a
place in Danny's kingdom would likely be
a welcome opportunity
I mean she's welcome to my kingdom at
least anytime I'll even care that she's
all old and stuff wait yeah I do family
reunion fans loved meeting lady Leanna
moment the pint-sized leader of Bear
Island her voice bends the will of even
the toughest leaders in the north and
she helped John Snow claim his throne at
Winterfell
I don't care if it's busted let's start
blood runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day she also just who happens to be
draw as first cousin the former Lord of
Bear Island has kept away from his home
since being exiled but maybe it's time
to return home in atone for his crimes
starting with a visit to lady Leanna so
he can plead for mercy that rekindled
connection with Leanna would certainly
get the ball rolling on introducing his
queen to the king in the north
dragon lover now that she's left a lover
Daario naharis to babysit the people of
marine Daenerys is single and ready
to mingle does that mean that you're now
eligible no yes I'm young I'm singer I
want a mango Jorah meanwhile is emitted
his true feelings for her I love you
[Music]
I'll always love you awkward Daenerys
has already indicated that she plans to
make her next marriages to teacher corn
that helps her unite with her one and
true love the iron throne so romantic
given the potential of the Mormon name
to help secure our audience of key
leaders in the north a marriage could
fulfill both their hearts desires and be
good for politics hey it could happen a
Song of Ice and Fire
let's not forget that Daenerys isn't the
only Thai garyun who needs allies for
the war ahead after all winter has
finally come to the north and the night
King could bring it everywhere else
Danny's fire-breathing dragons could be
just what snow needs to defeat the icy
Undead plus Dany already has an old
friend of John's on board Theon Greyjoy
Jorah with the influence of lianna and
possibly even Davos Seaworth
could finally bring the Targaryen family
together again to sing their song of ice
and fire thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment let us know which
role you think sir Jorah will play
[Music]